>> Ankur Kotwal: Hi everyone and welcome to
another APEC Android Developer Office Hours
session.
Thanks for joining us today.
We have Ryosuke here from Tokyo Japan.
>>Ryosuke Matsuuchi: Hello.
>> Ankur Kotwal: Hi Ryosuke.
And Tony Chang has just joined us as well
from Hong Kong.
>>Tony Chang: Hi Guys.
>> Ankur Kotwal: And I'm Ankur Kotwal and
I'm joining in from Sydney Australia.
So we actually don't have a lot of questions
today, so hopefully that means our global
teams have been doing a good job of answering
questions.
Or that people are still just really enjoying
themselves after IO.
Anyways, let's get started with the questions
that we have.
We have the Moderator thread.
So the first question is.
I'll read it out word for word and then I'll
interpret it.
It says "How to make a Google+ or YouTube
style slide menu?
It is not included in the Android design.
But I think it is good.
Is it included in the API?
If not, why not?"
So my understanding of this question is it's
referring to the slide out menu that you get
on the left hand side now in the Google+ and
the YouTube apps.
And basically it's a new kind of design style
that we see is getting popular.
And we're obviously starting to adopt it in
our official apps.
Right now, there is nothing available for
developers to build that themselves.
Having said that, we're actually planning
to update the Android design guide to show
you how to build it yourself.
We'll probably be providing some sample code
to go with it and then that way it will be
available to you.
So stay tuned.
It is coming.
Alright, next question is on Android Beam.
Tony.
>>Tony: Yeah, so let me take this one.
So the question was "We are excited when knowing
that Android Beam is having an upgrade during
the IO 2012.
Any reason on why Android Beam tech NFC plus
Bluetooth, not NFC plus wifi direct like SB.
To control device player than connect it by
controlling the Nexus Q.
Well, first of all, I don't think like, we
are in favor of one technology over another.
But that said, there is really some advantage
using Bluetooth.
So let me highlight them.
So the first one is in terms of power consumption.
Bluetooth is really doing very well.
Sometimes even better than wifi.
Another reason of choosing Bluetooth is when
you connect with to wifi direct, you have
to disconnect from the wifi network.
So that's how you still can connect to the
internet using radio connection, like using
your 3G or 4G radio.
But there is some kind of user, not smooth
user experience there.
And finally wifi direct is available in, I
believe, in ICS and so in terms of a compatibility,
Bluetooth NFC is probably much more compatible
in all the Android devices.
Hope that answered your question.
>>Ankur: Thanks Tony.
So the next question is one about Project
Butter.
So, just a quick introduction, Project Butter
is one of the big undertakings that we had
in Jelly Bean.
And it was really all about making the user
interface "buttery smooth" and highly responsive.
So Ryosuke, why don't you handle, take this
one.
>> Ryosuke: Sure.
Yeah, OK the question was, OK, I am reading
this.
"We have seen Project Butter in action at
the IO.
We would like to know if there is anything
we should do to make our applications better
by syncing our custom fields with re-sync.
Is there anything that we need to do explicitly
to enable this feature?"
This was a question from Bangalore India.
I think there would be several things I would
like to clarify.
First of all, this Project Butter is something
that you can divinate without changing your
code.
So it means that without doing anything on
Jelly Bean and above your application should
be already behaving much smoother than before.
And having said that, there are several APIs
that you can take out, in order to take further
advantage of this re-sync.
And I think that the most typical operation
that you would like to do, whenever re-sync
happens, probably you would like to simply
invalidate your field.
Actually, that this Android animation framework
already has a method for that.
And it is called view.postinvalidate on anime
shop.
When you say that, as soon as the display
print starts, you have, you get invalidated.
And if
[background voice]
Sorry?
>>Ankur: No, my mistake, sorry.
>> Ryosuke: Oh.
OK.
Yeah.
So.
This, so there are several other methods on
view, like post on animation, or post on animation
[diday].
Um, aside from post Invalidate on animation,
you can use these new methods.
These cross [inaudible] with other Android
animation framework.
And they are automatically synchronized with
the re-sync on Jelly Bean.
And these are simple APIs to use.
And also if you are rendering in some different
sled.
Outside of your own normal sled, possibly
you may be doing some custom rendering using
open DL or something.
In those cases you may not be actually using
the Android animation framework.
Still, you can divinate this Jelly Bean project
Butter by using our new API called Choreographer.
And this is a totally new API that we introduced
starting API developer 16.
And you can basically say that the, this Choreographer
API is you can use when you would like to
put your callback synchronized with this basic
timing.
So you can do whatever you want at the beginning
of this display REM cycle, using this Choreograph
mechanics.
And so this does not depend on Android animation
frameworks, so this is doable even if you
are doing anything you would like without
standard view link mechanism.
That was one explanation I was able to offer
for this question.
I hope this answers your question.
Thank you.
>>Ankur: Alright.
Well it looks like we have someone that's
joined us on the Hangout.
>> Ryosuke: OK.
>>Ankur: Pavan.
Hi Pavan.
>>Pavan: Yeah.
Pavan.
Yeah.
Hi.
>>Ankur: Nice to meet you.
So do you have any questions for us?
>>Pavan: No, actually I was looking for what
kind of group it is and what are you discussing,
guys, so is there anything I can chip in?
>>Ankur: I'm sorry, it's a little bit hard
to hear you Pavan.
Could you repeat what you said?
>>Pavan: I said I was looking, I was talking
and I was texting, maybe I can chip in what
you guys are discussing about.
>>Ankur: Well you've come in at an interesting
time because we've just sort of run out of
questions to answer.
>> Ryosuke: OK.
>>Ankur: So, you probably wanna catch the
YouTube recording afterwards and catch up
on the questions that we already answered.
So, um, yeah, if you have any of your own
questions at the moment, this is a good time
to ask.
If there's anyone, I can see that we've got
a number of viewers on the stream.
So if you have any questions that you'd like
us to, please post them to the thread.
We are we're ready and waiting to answer.
So Pavan while we have you here have you had
a chance to look at the YouTube videos from
Google IO?
>>Pavan: No, not yet.
>>Ankur: Not yet?
OK.
Have you done any Android development yourself?
>>Pavan: Yeah.
Basically we have, we have, uh, very few apps.
One basically that I particularly liked and,
basically, the app, publishing apps.
>>Ankur: OK.
Publishing apps.
Already on the market?
On play?
Sorry, I missed that.
>>Pavan: The two are developed privately.
>>Ankur: Oh, they're private builds.
OK.
Fair enough.
Well it looks like people are fairly quiet
today.
We've got 50 viewers at the moment and they
look shy so.
>>Tony: Yeah, I guess we should give them
some time to go over all the YouTube videos.
We have a lot of new content after Google
IO, so let's give them some time to digest
and probably next week we will have more questions.
>>Ankur: Yeah, I hope so.
So we'll be doing this weekly just like our
colleagues in the US as well as in the [miyat]
so our European colleagues there.
So we'll post up a moderator link next week.
And if there isn't anything else right now,
I guess we'll see you next time.
Alright?
>> Ryosuke: Sounds good.
>>Ankur: Alright.
Thanks Pavan for joining us.
Thanks Tony and thanks Ryosuke.
>>Ryosuke: OK.
>>Tony: Thank you.
Bye.
>>Ankur: See you everyone.
>>Ryosuke: Thank you very much.